e
signature d'un protocole d'accord entre
trois syndicats d'infirmières et le
ministre de la santé
réaction mitigée aux propositions de
valorisation de carrière émises par le
premier ministre pouvait retire
aujourd'hui de la campagne officielle
pour le référendum calédonien le
président mitterrand on voit une
nouvelle lettre aux français
première en israël yasser arafat
intervient dans la campagne électorale
il appelle juifs et arabes à voter pour
les forces de des offensives alès le
chancelier allemand helmut kohl et à
moscou priorité aux relations
économiques et financières
le couple maudit drogue sida plusieurs
médecins et chercheurs apportent un
soutien inattendu à une association très
controversé le patriarche mal à monsieur
bonsoir quand la politique s'empare
d'une oeuvre quelle qu'elle soit c'est
toujours mauvais signe c'est le signe de
l'intolérance de la censure des idées ou
de leurs expressions et c'est souvent
l'encouragement à la violence il y a
longtemps qu'on avait vu dans notre pays
pareil indignation orchestrée ou non à
l'encontre d'un film la tentation du
christ a donné lieu depuis trois
semaines vous le savez à toutes sortes
d'incidents en france deux personnes
sont ce soir encore à l'hôpital pour
avoir été blessé dans ce cinéma parisien
incendié samedi soir et voilà
aujourd'hui que la politique s'en empare
le front national reprend à son compte
la colère des intégristes des
communistes des socialistes et des
personnalités de tous bords manifestent
pour la liberté d'expression
véronique salive tentation provocation
tentation émotions
ce soir à l'appel de la gauche et
d'intellectuels plusieurs centaines de
parisiens ont défilé place saint michel
pour la liberté d'expression
l'attentât de samedi soir provoque
l'émotion de toute la classe politique
tous partis confondus personnes excuses
l'acte criminel tous inquiets de cette
intolérance qu'on croyait disparue mais
pour les uns la violence est celle d'un
film blasphématoire alors que pour les
autres la liberté d'expression ne se
divise pas dans ce il s'est agi d'une
grave agression contre la liberté
d'expression cela dit moi je ne suis pas
insensible aux sentiments qu'exprime un
certain nombre de croyants de
catholiques mais le même doivent
comprendre que le respect qu'il aurait
dû comme d'ailleurs à toutes confessions
à ceux qui n'ont pas de confession ce
respect est précisément il implique de
la liberté d'expression la tolérance ne
se divise pas bureau politique du front
national à condamner l'action criminelle
cet incendie d'un cinéma il note
cependant que d'une campagne semble
déclencher
alors que l' enquête n'a pas encore
établi les responsabilités du criminel
étendre cette responsabilité à tous ceux
qui ont manifesté contre la projection
regrettable à mon avis de ce film qui a
intérêt aujourd'hui à alimenter le
brasier et a soufflé sur les feux de
l'enfer
la brigade criminelle mène l'enquêté
aujourd'hui une seule salle parisienne
projette encore ce film sous la
protection de la police et le
britannique blessé samedi soir au cinéma
saint michel n'était même pas aller voir
la tentation du christ mais le film de
la salle voisine
le maire de paris jacques chirac
condamne avec indignation ce soir
l'attentât du cinéma quant à monseigneur
lustiger qui avait d'abord invoqué le
diable il fustige ce soir c'est large
qui dit il que contreviennent au respect
des lois et du christianisme fin de
citation la grève des infirmières est
enfin levé
trois syndicats la cfdt force ouvrière
elle
cftc ont officiellement accepté les
propositions du gouvernement l'a serré
c'est à refuser de signer ainsi que la
cgt qui veut poursuivre le mouvement
la coordination qui n'a pas été invitée
à signer l'accord en avait rejeté le
contenu hier pour elle la grève est
finie mais le mouvement de revendication
continue ce matin le premier ministre
michel rocard avait annoncé trois
mesures qui figurent pour partie dans le
protocole d'accord l'abrogation de
l'arrêté signé par le précédent ministre
de la santé michèle barzach qui avait
élargi les conditions d'entrée dans les
écoles d'infirmières la mise à l'étude
pour les infirmières qui ont 20 ans de
métier de l'accès au corps médical et la
poursuite du dialogue entre les
infirmières et le secrétaire d'état
chargé des droits de la femme maryse la
mano et nicolas jacobs ont ausculté les
réactions à ces propositions pour la
première fois dans cette école
d'infirmière à paris 45 % des élèves
n'avais pas le bac à la rentrée 88 c'est
la conséquence de l'arrêté barza qui a
volontairement baissé le niveau d'entrée
dans les écoles pour permettre l'accès
de la profession au plus grand nombre
cet arrêté est donc abrogé cette semaine
comme le prévoyait le protocole d'accord
signé cet après midi par les syndicats
je suis étonné que soit premier ministre
socialiste qui essaient de revenir sur
la promotion sociale de femmes et
d'hommes qui n'ont pas eu la chance à un
moment donné de pouvoir passer leur bac
et qui un jour reprenne section ça pour
accéder à un métier aiguille les
infirmières qui redoutaient la
déqualification obtiennent gain de cause
par rapport à l'abrogation de l'article
iv de madame barzakh c'est une bonne
chose mais en fait c'est quand même
dommage que cela arrive après un mois de
conflit
en revanche sur la possibilité pour une
infirmière d'entrer dans le corps
médical
après vingt ans d'ancienneté et une
formation les infirmières sont peu
intéressés
je pense qu'il faudrait des châles
claire par rapport à lessac
nous mêmes de nous infirmières déjà
définir celui là correctement après on
verra pour l'instant il ne s'agit encore
que d'une idée mais sa réalisation sera
difficile réticences du corps médical
des gens surnombre d'une part et
difficultés pour les infirmières d'autre
part de reprendre des études
après 40 ans reprise discrète des
contacts entre le ministre de la
fonction publique michel durafour et les
syndicats de fonctionnaires aujourd'hui
michel rocard entend mettre sur pied
deux groupes de réflexion pour étudier
le problème des rémunérations et des
conditions de travail
andré bergeron se dit sceptique
maintenant que le front social est un
peu plus dégagé le premier ministre
choisit de remonter en première ligne
pour défendre le référendum sur l'avenir
de la nouvelle calédonie ce matin sur
europe 1 il avait qualifié de factieuses
l'attitude du rpr qui sous couvert de
prôner l'abstention laissé entendre que
le résultat du scrutin n'aurait pas
force définitive réplique d'alain juppé
monsieur rocard a visiblement la fièvre
si le oui l'emporté le rpr respecterait
les accords et le texte du projet de loi
référendaire at il dit en tout cas la
campagne officielle a commencé
aujourd'hui
comme de coutume les différents partis
en misant au point leur panoplie le
président mitterrand lui intervient à sa
manière par une lettre aux français qui
accompagnent le matériel de vote
laurent boussier ce référendum ne
marquera ni le triomphe d'un quand il a
défait d'un autre il consacrera la
victoire de la paix lettre de françois
mitterrand aux électeurs lettre qui
ressemble étonnamment au texte que
raymond barre a rendu public cet après
midi l'ancien premier ministre appelle
lui aussi à répondre massivement oui le
6 novembre
surprenante campagne électorale où les
partis politiques semblent en retrait
par rapport à la campagne faite par le
gouvernement appelle à voter oui par
voie de clips télé ou d'affiche coûte 20
millions de francs et rôle actif du
premier ministre qui participera à
quatre grands meetings en province et
qui a fait du règlement de la sphère
calédonienne une de ses priorités
les membres du gouvernement sont mises à
contribution alain de colle
ministre délégué à la francophonie va
mettre ses talents de conteur au service
du oui en racontant l'histoire de ce
territoire du bout du monde
côté partis politiques la campagne plus
sobre appello il y avait quand même huit
grands meetings et 500 mille affiches
imprimées et des dépliants pour le parti
socialiste campagne en métropole pour
jean marie tjibaou et le fln ks pendant
une semaine
oui sans enthousiasme pour le parti
communiste
et oui du bout des lèvres pour l'udf au
rpr abstention ne veut pas dire absence
de campagne affiches dépliants et lettre
de jacques chirac aux militants pour
expliquer la position politique du parti
gaulliste leitmotiv ne pas cautionner la
politique de michel rocard
enfin pour le nom le cni s'affiche sur
les murs des villes et le front national
ces campagnes
jean-marie le pen reprend la route des
meetings une dizaine d'ici le 6 novembre
f -mitterrand les salaires les
conditions de travail des militants cgt
des ptt des hôpitaux ont ainsi essayé d'
apostrophes et sans succès cet après
midi le président de la république le
monsieur mitterrand accompagné de jack
lang inaugurait à l'île saint germain
près de paris une tour un peu
particulière la tour aux figures signée
jean dubuffet que vous découvrez la
l'état continuera de passer commande aux
artistes a dit monsieur mitterrand sur
fond de sono cgt commentaire de charles
pasqua que vous voyez accompagnant le
chef de l'état hôte en tant que
président du conseil général des
hauts-de-seine
monsieur pasqua il faudrait qu'il cesse
c'est quand même le président de la
république des grèves a signalé ici et
là qui perturbe tantôt la distribution
du courrier dans certains quartiers de
paris à rouen et à lille qui
perturbaient aussi à paris métro et rer
débrayage encore à air france mais sans
conséquence sur le trafic
si côté des personnels techniques qui
assure l'entretien des avions manoeuvre
financière dénoyautage et revanche
georges pébereau l'ancien patron de la
compagnie générale d'électricité qui
avait été évincé en 86 contrôler ce soir
plus de 9% du capital de la société
générale
il reprend ainsi pied dans la cge dont
la société générale est l'une des
premiers actionnaires
les israéliens votent dans huit jours
sans connaître la trêve l'aviation
israélienne a mené ce matin un nouveau
raid sur une base militaire au sud liban
et des troupes sont massés ce soir à la
frontière
c'est pourtant yasser arafat qui est ce
soir au centre de l'effervescence
politique en israël pour la première
fois en effet l'ol paie intervient
publiquement dans la campagne électorale
une manière implicite de reconnaître les
institutions israéliennes
une façon explicite de peser sur le vote
de jérusalem les explications de
challans dern ce texte en hébreu est
arrivé en début d'après midi en israël
c'est l'appel de yasser arafat aux
électeurs israéliens pour qu'ils votent
en faveur du camp de la paix est la
dernière en date des interventions
extérieures dans la campagne électorale
après les prises de position du roi de
jordanie et le sommet moubarak hussein
arafat d'aqaba des événements qui ont
été au centre du duel télévisé d'hier
soir entre itzhak shamir le chef du
likoud la droite et le travailliste
shimon peres roll'on un quartier de la
banlieue de tel-aviv où on affiche ses
opinions au premier sur le balcon d
avigdor une banderole voté travailliste
au second les shiloh art conseil de
voter likoud ya cauvel oravig d'or
étaient inquiets shimon peres fatigue et
risquer de perdre des points
à l'étagé au dessus elie et myriam
chinois he était confiant persuadé
qu'ils traitent shamir saura faire
passer son message
tout d'abord je dois dire qu'une telle
ingérence d'un dirigeant arabe le roi
hussein dans la campagne électorale est
inadmissible sans précédent et il faut
la condamner
et puis une conférence internationale
comme le propose monsieur perez ce
serait une défaite israélienne
monsieur perez lui-même le disait en 85
et alors perez a changé d'opinion il
s'est passé des choses depuis
si seulement tous les compliments du
likoud était vrai si effectivement le
monde arabe dansaient au son de la
musique de
mon parti non je ne dis pas que nous
ferons la pète tout de suite mais
donnez-moi une possibilité d'essayer de
relancer le processus de paix d'entamer
des négociations après l'émission les
chinois n'ont pas résisté ils sont
descendu chez les avigdor vont les
travaillistes vous avez perdu shamir a
été très bon perez était convaincant il
faut se retirer des territoires avec des
arrangements de sécurité
la situation actuelle est insupportable
je viens de faire 60 jours de réserves
en cisjordanie et s'il faut j'en ferai
plus encore si on rend les territoires
c'est à jaffa tel-aviv qu on lancera dès
pierre perez conduire à la catastrophe
le duel télévisé n'a rien changé
apparemment les sondages donnent
toujours la droite et la gauche
à égalité et l'initiative de yasser
arafat s'inscrit dans une manoeuvre
diplomatique en faveur d'une conférence
internationale de paix manoeuvre soutenu
par la jordanie et l'egypte l'egypte où
doit se rendre demain le président
mitterrand qui en discutera sûrement
avec le président moubarak
question qui est l'homme politique le
plus populaire en allemagne fédérale
réponse pour plus de 70 % d'allemands
mikhaïl gorbatchev c'est avec ce chiffre
en tête que le chancelier helmut kohl
est arrivé tout à l'heure à moscou où
une visite officielle de quatre jours
elin en ce moment même au kremlin où il
vient de lancer un vibrant appel à la
réunification de l'allemagne et au libre
mouvement des biens et des idées entre
l'est et l'ouest des biens surtout si
l'on songe que la semaine dernière un
groupe de banques allemandes a prêté à
l'union soviétique plus de 10 milliards
de francs et que l'allemagne fédérale
entend bien bénéficier de la
restructuration économique voulu par
moscou
philippe rochot 3 milliards de
deutschemarks prêté par neuf banques
allemandes 11 milliards de francs de
crédits sans taux préférentiels pour
permettre à l'urss de relancer les
échanges avec l'allemagne fédérale et à
l'allemagne fédérale de renforcer sa
position sur l'immense marché soviétique
à l'heure de la transparence les grands
patrons de l'industrie allemande comme
volkswagen espère améliorer leur percée
en urss
une vingtaine de contrats seront donc
signé durant le voyage du chancelier
kohl
il vise aussi par le biais de l'économie
a renforcé la position politique
de mikhaïl gorbatchev des soviétiques
vont acheter des machines des biens
d'équipement pour moderniser leur
industrie notamment leurs industries de
consommation pour produire pour mieux
satisfaire les besoins de la population
autre aspect capital le réacteur
nucléaire de 200 mégawatts que
l'allemagne fédérale va construire sur
les bords de la volga et la signature
d'un accord sur la sécurité nucléaire
civil pour éviter un nouveau tchernobyl
et puis l'espace l'allemagne fournira
une partie de sa technologie de pointe à
l'urss et un cosmonaute allemand
participera à un bol soviétique en
accordant un tel soutien économique et
financier à l'urss les allemands veulent
tout aussi soutenir à dirigeants qui est
ici deux fois plus populaire que ronald
reagan
mikhaïl gorbatchev considéré comme
l'homme clé de la détente entre l'est et
l'ouest
les retombées du voyage du chancelier
kohl à moscou seront donc économique et
surtout politique
son nom rugby c'est un typhon qui est en
train de ravager les philippines avec
des vents de 200 kilomètres heure
un navire aurait sombré tout à l'heure
avec plus de 500 personnes à bord et en
amérique centrale c'est un cyclone
rebaptisé myriam kir a ravagé le
guatemala
emmanuel vanier des vents soufflant à
plus de 200 kilomètres heure plusieurs
centaines de morts des centaines de
milliers de sans abri
six jours un ouragan ravages l'amérique
centrale selon les spécialistes c'est
l'une des plus grave catastrophe
naturelle qu'ait connue cette région du
monde au nicaragua la ville portuaire de
bluefields a été littéralement rayés de
la carte
les habitations de bois balayée par les
bourrasques toutes les communications
coupées 10% de la population du
nicaragua est sinistré la cee vient de
débloquer une aide d'urgence de trois
millions et demi de francs pour acheter
vivres et médicaments
après avoir repris des forces dans le
pacifique l'ouragan se dirige à présent
vers le sud vers le salvador où
plusieurs villes côtières ont été
évacuées
reprise ce matin à bruxelles du procès
des responsables présumés du drame du sl
2 seulement des 24 où les gars n'étaient
présents le tribunal a commencé
l'analyse des faits pièces à conviction
30 heures de films vidéo tournée le soir
du drame
le procès a été suspendu jusqu'à
mercredi le visionnage des films durera
encore au moins une semaine après
seulement pourront débuter les
interrogatoires
vente demain soir à new york de la
correspondance privée d'anne frank des
lettres adressées à sa soeur margot et
a2 américaine qui avait conservé les
documents depuis plus de 40 ans on en
parle moins depuis quelques mois mais le
sida continue de faire ses ravages
notamment parmi les toxicomanes
vous vous souvenez de la controverse qui
entoure depuis 4 ou 5 ans et centres
d'accueil pour drogués regroupés dans
l'association le patriarche et bien
alain labouze et jean-françois bernigaud
ont visité un centre près de toulouse
leur découverte ce ne sont plus
seulement des malades de la drogue mais
bien du sida qui sont concentrées là et
des problèmes nouveaux se pose un chalet
à 20 km de toulouse et 25 pensionnaires
25 jeunes qui mène une vie apparemment
tranquille
pourtant parmi eux il ya vingt malades
du sida va malades du patriarche
le patriarche c'est-à-dire 5000 ex
toxicomane qui dans des communautés
comme celles ci font le sevrage brutal
des nouveaux arrivants 65% d'entre eux
sont séropositifs
rien qu'en france ils sont déjà 280
malades du sida à vivre au rythme très
particulier du patriarche
je le dis parfois par boutade le bit
dans un sanatorium tout le monde se
réveille à 7 heures du matin où tout le
monde prend son petit déjeuner à 7 se
raidit c'est probablement la plus grosse
réussite du patriarche et 5000 personnes
qui se lève à 7h du matin et qui ont
envie d'un café et pas de poule pour
cent 1 6 1 au terme des premiers en
anesthésie pas d'états d'âme à avoir
face à l'épidémie de sida accédant à
toute allure chez les toxicomanes
il faut un sevrage et une prise en
charge s'il le faut muscler
je suis ancien toxicomane mais entendu
j'ai pas été que médecins hospitaliers
j'étais toxico pendant près de dix ans
et c'est pas facile et j'ai subi une
certaine forme de coercition on m'a
fouillé quand je suis arrivé je me suis
battu dans les quinze premiers jours et
par parenthèse je remercie le pied au
cul de certains qui ont permis
simplement qu'aujourd'hui je suis en
train de répondre à vos questions
c'est totalement arrêté les trocs et se
vit super bien j'ai la pêche maritime
formidable à l'extérieur c'est chacun
pour soi
ici c'est vraiment les copains la
mythique coupe moi j'aime khatami ouija
mari femme habituée marié oui il vit
avec moi et les sont positifs aussi que
des enfants
j'ai un petit garçon de 13 ans et demi
parce que le sida ça fait peur ici
ensemble quoi ça fait peur plus
qu'ailleurs comme ça mais j'ai au
contraire on est plus en sécurité ici
que de mort parce qu'on sait qui c'est
qui qui est positif qui c'est qui est
négative et on a moins de risques
d'attraper devoir parce que dehors c'est
pas écrit sur le fronton et legacy
repositionne tout irait donc pour le
mieux
seulement voilà -2 2% reste dans la
communauté
au delà de deux ans il est difficile de
savoir vraiment combien s'en sortent
définitivement alors le patriarche est
ce bien des centres de santé ou bien
est-ce une secte que c'est une secte
je sais pas des gens qui sont toxico qui
se défoncent qui clame dans la rue
transmettre le virus du sida
kiki qui font qu'ils rentrent dans un
circuit complètement marginalisés et
qu'ils quitteraient v qui propose de la
drogue à des gens qui utilisent qui
n'ont pas encore touché à cette
saloperie qui viennent ici qui retrouve
goût à la vie qui se soigne qui
construisent demain qui partent et qui
vivent chez pas comment on pourrait
qualifier cette association pendant
l'épidémie de sida
la vie continue ici en marge des
autorités sanitaires
la drogue ne serait donc plus un
problème reste alors le risque de
transmission du virus par voie sexuelle
depuis toujours il ya une certaine
période de il ya une période de
quarantaine de l'admission est libre de
tout et de tout rapport sexuel
les mises en couple ne se font pas aussi
facilement que ça c'est quelque chose
qui est discuté à l'intérieur de chaque
centre en particulier en ce qui concerne
les légendes sérologie différente où les
gens qui sont tous les deux sirops
positif pour les malades c'est en groupe
on se raccroche à des expérimentations
de nouveaux traitements
cela se passe bien loin de l'hôpital et
pour le centre sans reconnaissance
officielle du ministère de la santé saïd
est malade depuis huit mois
son sida il le vivra jusqu'au bout dans
les mystères du patriarche
et puis voici qu'une vingtaine de
médecins et de chercheurs apportent un
soutien un soutien inattendu au
patriarche professeur chermann
vous vous faites partie de ces médecins
la con soir on sait que vous poursuivez
à marcher vos recherche sur les virus du
sida
alors pourquoi portez-vous votre
soutient une association qui on le voit
concentre quand même les sidéens dans
des lieux clos est ce que ce n'est pas
choquant ou je crois que c'est pas tout
à fait ça j'ai été visité un centre à
côté de barcelone j'ai pas vu celui de
toulouse
mais j'ai vu ce qui se passait en ce qui
concernait les séropositifs par exemple
comment les accueillaient comment on les
entouraient et comment on les amener à
l'hôpital quand il avait quelque chose
c'est à dire que le vous savez quand on
traite le sida c'est généralement
l'hôpital de jour on sort et on revient
on reste quelques jours dans cet hôpital
mais quand on les toxicomanes eh bien on
retourne dans la rue et là on recommence
à serez infectés
ici il retourne dans un endroit qui
s'appelle l'espace de santé où on les
suit et reviennent ils suivent leur
traitement
voilà ce que j'ai vu ce que j'ai vu
aussi j'ai vu des jeunes garçons j'ai vu
des gens qui ont promis d' aborde sans
anonymat de ne plus transmettre le virus
à une se drogue plus deuxièmement ils
mettent des préservatifs et je crois que
tous ces jeunes ce sont des jeunes et
bien ont été arrachées de la drogue
douce on le sait c'est la drogue est là
maintenant ils sont menacés du sida je
crois que là nous nous avons quelque
chose à faire et à les aider
l'autre chose que je veux dire c'est que
on les dénigrent vous avez attaqué en
disant surprenant non je crois que c'est
surprenant question je vais signer à
quel point le problème du sida pousse
aussi dans notre société qu'il n'y est
pas préparé du tout toutes sortes de
problèmes d'environnement social donc la
question que pose ce genre de centre c
est ce que certaines pratiques comme
celles qui peuvent dans certains cas
semble-t-il c'est ce qu'on dit ces
jeunes être favorable aux toxicomanes
est ce qu'on peut tolérer les mêmes
pratiques pour les sidéens non je crois
je crois pas que ce soit les mêmes
pratiquera j'ai pas bien compris la
question
ce que je veux dire simplement c'est que
ces toxicomanes ex toxicomane qui
maintenant sont séropositifs sont quand
même suivi par les meilleurs
spécialistes à marseille c'est casanova
gastaud à strasbourg ces langues à lyon
c'est très peu à toulouse c'est
armengaud tous professeurs 1 2 2 dans
les service de maladies infectieuses et
je crois que si vous voulez et aussi ces
jeunes garçons ou ces toxicomanes
séropositifs et bien deviennent la proie
des essais thérapeutiques vous rendez
compte la chance on a des séropositifs
qui ne se drogue plus donc ils ne
seraient contaminés plus et qui ne sont
même ne re contamine plupart le la
seringue
mais qui ne sera contamine plus non plus
par le sexe donc là on peut voir
effectivement l'efficacité des
médicaments sur le virus et je crois que
là on les reconnaît comme étant très
très favorable vous voyez ce que je veux
dire parce que ça veut dire que vous
êtes pour finalement le regroupement de
sidéens toksun maman
être pas dire ce que je ne dis ne faites
pas dire ce que je ne dis pas ce que je
dis là c'est que généralement un
toxicomane malades qui arrivent à
l'hôpital
et bien pendant les huit jours il va
rester à l'hôpital il va se sentir bien
il va être entouré le neuvième jour il
va sortir et il va revenir le lendemain
dans le couloir passez qui sait pas bien
nous aller et il valait dans la rue et
dans la rue qu'est ce qu'il va faire eh
bien on va recommencer
bon là ces jeunes sont sortis des
toxicomanies on les fait travailler ils
s'amusent ils ont créé un orchestre et
4,6 un jour à une émission un peu plus
longue
faites passer leur caste et 4 ont viré
quatre jeunes toxicomanes ex-toxicomane
excusez-moi séropositifs qui font de la
musique de la très bonne musique
vous verrez des sportifs regarder un
match de football entre toxicomanes ex
toxicomanes séropositifs et d'autres
équipes etc
il faut les voir vivre et ça je crois
que s'il ya quelque chose qui est fait
et à mon avis bien fait et j'ai été voir
et je vous engage et j'engage la plupart
des gens à passer un peu plus de temps
avant de dire tout ce qu'on peut
entendre là dessus voilà ce que je
voulais dire dans sa main merci et à une
autre manifestation que vous le souple
et particulièrement cette initiative des
charlots qui à partir de demain vendredi
sq pour pas que l'amour capote c'est un
disque qui sera vendue uniquement en
pharmacie donc à partir de demain pour
encourager les gens et singulièrement
les jeunes à utiliser des préservatifs
interpellation aujourd'hui à nyon d'un
homme soupçonné de deux viols commis en
mai dernier
il s'agit de luc tangorre déjà condamné
pour des viols qu'il a toujours nié
éric perrin luc tangorre libre c'était
il ya huit mois
ce matin il a été à nouveau interpellé à
lyon condamné en 1983 à 15 ans de
réclusion criminelle pour onze viols
ce marseillais de 28 ans a toujours
clamé son innocence
en février dernier il obtient sa
libération conditionnelle et réclament
la révision du procès un comité de
soutien regroupant près de 5000
personnes s'étaient formés un livre
avait même été écrit coupable à tout
prix et c'est ce livre qui a mis les
enquêteurs du viol en mai dernier de
deux américaines qui faisaient du stop
près denis
sur la piste de luc tangorre les deux
victimes avaient en effet aperçu dans la
voiture de leur agresseur un ouvrage
dont le titre commencer par coupable
deuxième indice le violeur avait une 4l
vert pomme
or les parents de l'udc aurait une
voiture similaire cet après midi luc
tangorre a été confronté aux deux jeunes
américaines qui l'aurait reconnu comme
l'auteur du double viol le tennis
maintenant avec le tournoi de bercy
le tournoi a démarré aujourd'hui daniel
cazals on n'entend pas daniel kazan et
on a même du mal à voir qu'ils jouent eh
bien il vous le dira tout ça tout à
l'air dans le dernier journal que vous
présentera henri sannier rapidement
encore les pronostics de pierrette brès
pour le car c'est de demain à vincennes
15 le 14 9 8 le 6 le 11 le 5 le 1 et le
3 voilà donc dernier journal avec henri
sannier à 22h30 merci d'avoir suivi ce
journal vous avez rendez vous demain à
6h45 comme tous les matins avec roger
zabel très bonne soirée à demain 20
heures
oh